ich habe noch nichts getroffen hier das
ist echt verrückt wenn die zeiten auch
das war
[Musik]
hallo ich treffe heute den
generalsekretär der fdp niedersachsen
den innenpolitischen sprecher der fdp
und den sprecher der jungen gruppe der
fdp und das verrückte ist
ich treffe heute nur eine person
herzlich willkommen constantin h ich
mache mir ein bisschen sorgen sich auch
weil drei parteien bleibt da überhaupt
noch zeit für lukrative nebenjobs
das muss man dann an den nagel hängen
aber anna politik richtig machen will
hat man den rest nicht so viel zeit und
sie waren so richtig politiker sind
trotzdem in die fdp ist manchmal ein
bisschen schwierig oder ja aber man
gewöhnt sich ja ich finde sie sind
unserem partner typ ist dass in der fdp
vor oder nachteil einerseits
alleinstellungsmerkmal andererseits
außenseiter ich vielleicht alle bei uns
zwischen politischen andere zum handeln
auf bundeswehr und im nieder so kann man
richtig so
ich dachte wir den dingen geht es heute
gab es geht hier aber um alle dann würde
ich sagen
[Musik]
los geht's
für euch gehts gleich ins jahr 2007 das
ist die einzige menschen überlebt haben
ja ein windrad von der fdp
das ist aber unfair wird man den grünen
über 20 prozent ja
[Musik]
ich sehe sie jetzt auch hier sehen sie
mich denn aber nur so schematisch na
also ja okay also wir haben jetzt noch
wir haben noch kein gesicht wir haben
noch kein profil auch das kennt man bei
der fdp
wir können uns jetzt sogar theoretisch
fahrer machen obwohl darf man das in
corona wir sind ja virtual den dingern
nach ras okay hier kann man sich den
avatar aussuchen ja ganz genau wir haben
also viel tiere fuchs eule kuh und affe
wo fühlen sie sich am ehesten hingezogen
hat zum fuchs natürlich ich habe mir
gedacht hier geht darum warum der funken
aber der fuchs schlau ist der volksweise
läuft aber er hat auch die gans
gestohlen gibt da ja wieder her
was jetzt hast du mir was würden sie
sagen hier das schwein da es gibt
überhaupt los ich dachte es ist das in
spanien wollte mich hier direkt hier
irgendwie wissen oder was ein schwein
das ist nur dann nehmen sie doch die kuh
den affen
er ist das perfekte ziel für die
bananenrepublik
jetzt muss man das hier in so einen
bottich rein tun
und zack sind sie der fuchs so das ist
unser raumschiff finden
er rät und lars weltin für diese mission
wenn ich mich so umschaue hätte die
politik vielleicht doch besser auf
youtube werden sollen also was soll mir
darüber wir müssen die beiden finden
mehrmals signal bekommen von der erde da
ja so und es gibt verschiedene sachen
die leuchten
es gibt halt jeden fall hier diese ampel
okay was ja und da könnte man ja mal
gucken ob das farblich da so rein dass
wir haben ja mit 13 ihren schülerausweis
gefälscht ja ich habe meinen genau ich
hab mein geburtsjahr falsch angegeben
bei den jungen liberalen ja
normalerweise anlass um alkohol zu
machen sie sich bitte mal ein bisschen
nützlich ist weil ja sonst aber aber
lieber zweifel wie dies orientiert ist
man als jugendlicher wenn man den aus
schüler aus alsfeld und dann der fdp
beizutreten
dass man kann seine jugend auch anders
verbringen aber es war schon im
nachhinein ganz witzig und ich habe eine
menge gelernt und genau aber man kann
auch andere dinge machen dass
jugendliche das stimmt schon aber andere
macht wahnsinn bilder typ
naja ich weiß nicht so übernahm kam ganz
drauf an kann man es auf die tageszeit
und auf die pegel an würde ich sagen
hier ist nun sind wir schon länger das
könnten damit können kämpfen
was sind sie soll auf gewalt ausgehen ja
das sieht jetzt wahrscheinlich das liegt
wahrscheinlich in der echten realität
nicht so geil aus wie virtuell aber
vielleicht sieht es auch in der realität
total geil aus man könnte schon sagen
wie bei den koalitionen er muss man so
ein bisschen die richtige auswählen wo
das irgendwie gelb nicht dabei ist nee
das ist schon absichtlich das ist ganz
nah der realität so was machen wir denn
jetzt also jetzt würde ich folgendes
sagen sie stecken noch mal ihren
schwengel also den sommer das sind
formuliert das nicht so zweideutig
klingen wie sie sie stecken
pinken stark in der pinkel loch das ja
irgendwie rum so andersrum
ja okay noch mal hier und jetzt nochmal
den blauen der sich gleich öffnet man
muss immer noch einmal rein stecken
hast du sie stellten anhand sie stecken
sie stecken den so oft gott noch mal ist
wir machen so eine porno version fürs
tag nennt noch jetzt stecke ich den in
dem jetzt stellt sie den blauen haus
stellen den blauen den blauen verloren
wo der haut erzeugt
jetzt habe ich schon wieder schnell
schnell attackieren sie gehen sie
einfach mal durch und sagen sie mir was
passiert
okay sie leben noch man komme ich mit
was sehr dunkel aber schön
wir können ja ein spiegeln die
laserstrahlen steuern das machen
also hätte christian lindner gewusst
dass hier so viele spiele sind er den
job angenommen oder aber kann man sich
darin überhaupt sehen ist ein eitler typ
was würden sie sagen
erleben sie das neue system basiert in
rohr ist gar nicht was das ist ja das
ist es doch oder
es ist okay dass ich sie das alles
machen lassen ja ich hab mir spaß
ja klar der meeresspiegel jetzt sie
müssen mich das schon machen dann aber
doch gut sie machen das sagt gar nichts
mehr
so jetzt wie schwierig ist das
eigentlich die die regierung zu
kritisieren und deren maßnahmen ohne
dass man direktional hygiene demo
eingeladen wird das ist ganz einfach man
muss das einfach sachlich machen
er ist ja sagen was man meint ja so wie
herr kemmerich
naja ich meine schon dass wir das im
bundestag ganz gut hingekriegt der aber
er hat es doch wieder versaut und geht
dann bei der hygiene dem moment zieht
sich den mundschutz nicht an also das
gesetz des zufalls müsse dafür sorgen
dass er einmal war es richtig macht oder
aber haben sich unsere geile aktion im
bundestag gesehen wie wir da die
regierung kritisiert haben dass wohl
auch super eine geile aktion von der fdp
im bundestag haben sich nicht erinnern
wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal kurzem ist
uns kurz mal zusammen ja wir sind kurz
die besprechung hier da ist was grünes
und der grüne weil und das weiß man
jetzt sein
wohin sie können es ja nirgendwo
hinschmeißen klär mich motiviert sein
kurz überlegen die stellen sich vor sie
werfen auf den politischen gegner
wer ist das die extremisten würde ich
sagen der politische gegner versuchen
unser land zu einem anderen mann zu
machen
die sind der gegner und gegen die müssen
wir zusammenstehen und auf die müssen
wir werfen sorgen
scheiße ich habe nicht getroffen man hat
das gefühl die fdp besteht nur aus
christian lindner das stimmt doch nicht
einfach nur so
das ist ja das ist doch quatsch wie
finden sie das nicht eingeladen wenn die
fdp weiß ja nicht wollte leben genommen
ja aber das hat ja jemand anders
gefunden ist ja aber es ist doch so
warum sind eine letzte garnitur wurde
dann hierher geschickt der schönheit die
fdp besteht natürlich nicht nur aus
christian ja aber gefühlt schon wenn man
sich das realistisch ein
das stimmt ja ich hab noch nichts
getroffen hier das nicht zurück wenn die
zeiten rauer
das war das auch alles gut alles gut
so muss doch mal hier ein bisschen was
sie angehen dass ein absoluter wahnsinn
es darf aber es macht spaß das war ihm
spaß macht es mehr spaß als politik ja
auf jeden fall um himmels willen
gut dass ich kein politiker geworden
kann ja noch kommen
sind sie nicht sogar meine die fdp
eingetreten neben den freundlichen dass
wir die spd
ach so es soll ich sie mal damit
bewerfen
wir machen sie mal aus spaß und gucken
was passiert wir haben wir nur noch drei
minuten
jetzt konzentrieren was fehlt noch blau
blau fehlt noch ich habe auch scheiße
wir müssen jetzt wir müssen jetzt das
kennen sie nicht wir müssen jetzt
teamwork machen ja so und jetzt nochmal
die dinger rein
[Musik]
die menschheit ist gering so einfach ist
das
ich wollte gerade mit ihnen einschlagen
und haben sich weggedreht schuldig so
ein mega peinlicher moment das kennt die
fdp doch diese momente
ich schwitze wie ein apfel ehrlich total
das liegt daran dass wir am strand sind
also haben wir zwei möglichkeiten der
coole ja ich würde haben wir sie haben
noch zwei minuten laufen oder
bogenschießen laufen
ich war maschinen sind auf diesen dingen
auf die scheibe hat die fdp das von dem
bogenberg
wir sind konstante spannung übrig sagt
wir sind immer unter spannung
wieder so ein politiker antworten nicht
jetzt mich abschießen weil ich meine
frage gestellt das ihnen nicht passen
so geht es ja nicht
die zeit ist abgelaufen eure zeit 41 36
war auch gut gemacht
[Musik]
das war eine heftige aktionär es
geschafft erklärt wir sind während der
reagan oder das ist das nächste
wer weiß wird dass das hier auch
kulturell und ich wäre hätte sie am
liebsten
ich hätte gerne horst seehofer
mitgenommen was so ein break unter
dienstmagd dagelassen das wäre eine
möglichkeit wie sie endlich mal
loszuwerden das bundesheer ist
mitgekommen und sie trauriger sonntag
geht es wieder zurück ins triste leben
eines fdp-politikers alles gute
wir haben spaß sonst welche letzten
worte sie irgendwo wenn das war der
knaller haben die welt gerettet und es
ist möglich wenn man sich anstrengt ein
paar gute lena dann geht es auch wenn
man eine begleitung hat die sich
überhaupt nicht anstrengend und
überhaupt nicht mithilft man kann es
schaffen
es ist möglich sagt ein politiker von
der fdp
[Musik]
hey leute das hält das ist ja der totale
wahnsinn dass das ist ja so als wäre ich
in den videos direkt drin und auch der
abo button der ist total riesig hier
abonnieren
wisst ihr auch mal machen und man kann
er total leichten die videos reiben
müssen
das bin ich bei derart die sonderbaren
ist dann eine reise prozent sind nicht
erfolgt